this is what I think would be closer to
what Henry the fifth a combat leader
woulda sounded like as he as he answered
some one of his subordinate leaders out
there in the crowd saying that we need
more people we need more men I think
this is what he would have sounded like
what's he that wishes so my cousin
Westmoreland know my fair cousin if we
are marked to die we are enough to do
our country loss and if to live the
fewer men the greater share of Honor
God's will I pray thee wish not one more
man by Jove I am NOT covetous for gold
nor care I who doth feed upon my cost it
earns me not if men my garments where
such outward things dwell not in my
desires but if it be a sin to covet
honor I am the most offending soul alive
no faith my coz wish not a man from
England God's peace I would not lose so
great an honor as one man more methinks
would share from me for the best hope I
have or do not wish one more rather
proclaim it Westmoreland through my host
that he which hath no stomach to this
fight let him depart his passport shall
be made and crowns for convoy shall be
put into his purse we would not die in
that man's company that fears his
fellowship to die with us
this day is called the feast of Crispian
li that outlives this day and comes home
safe who will stand a tiptoe when that
day is named and rouse him at the name
of Crispian he that shall see this day
and live old age will yearly on the
vigil feast his neighbours and say
tomorrow is Saint Crispian then will he
strip his sleeve and show his scars and
say these wounds I had on Crispin's day
old men forget yet all shall be forgot
but he'll remember with advantages what
feats he did that day then shall all
names familiar in his mouth as household
words Harry the King Bedford and Exeter
Warwick and Talbot Salisbury and
Gloucester be in their flowing cups
freshly remember'd this story shall the
good man teach his son and Crispin
Crispian shall ne'er go by from this day
to the ending of the world but we in it
shall be remembered with you we happy
few we band of brothers for who for he
today that sheds his blood with me shall
be my brother be near so vile this day
shall gentle his condition and gentlemen
in England now Abed shall think
themselves accursed they were not here
and hold their manhoods cheap whiles any
speaks that fought with us upon Saint
Crispin's day